pose est qui file maintenant vers la
ligne d'arrivée soit un bus ou un petit
peu en cours ou 7 3 puis 2 minutes
j'ai passé loin du compte c'était normal
rochel chery ces bruits là vous êtes
leur rapide a permis deux minutes dans
la vue aller aux ali avec la troisième
violent avec la troisième et ce sera
brasserie lorraine est donc pour
l'instant on attend l'arrivée de
brasserie lorraine haut niveau donc de
cette boue et un bras si le red star a
donc énergies nouvelles qui est arrivé
est dans un instant c'est une question
peut-être encore à régis minutes à
arriver d'autres alain vous restez au
chaud arrive et deux aides pour aborder
on est en grands vainqueurs on arrive on
a fait une très belle course on a mené
toute la course on a contrôlé
l'adversité puis en arrivant grands
vainqueurs dans la capitale aujourd'hui
la yole rosette/orange à cole avait
promis il l'a fait voilà rosette orange
qui donne une victoire d'étape à la
ville du françois
rosette orange qui a obtenu son pari
gagné à fort de france alors maintenant
je rappelle qu'à la boue et de la tôle
luminar avec le comité martiniquais du
tourisme présidée par carl rousseau d
avec 4 minutes 30 secondes avant centre
roses et oranges et il a pété gerber la
panoz à aller aux ali vous allez
intervenir pour les autres position
mahnaz tendance et rosette qui a bien
gagné un signal de brasserie lorraine le
troisième à plus de civils de talent et
rosalie hale et rosalie d'ici quelques
secondes en reste au niveau de la wii
avec cette fois-ci laguiole mutuelle
mare gaillard dont il cherche emploi cie
recherche en france qui arrive
maintenant quatrième position fr
champions
on me rappelle les quarts voilà 6,15
pourriez faire chance là je rappelle
quatre premières violent à la bouitte de
l'atome luminar du cnt comité
martiniquais du tourisme
rosette devant appétit gerber
l'appaloosa le leader du tour à chaque
minute par cinq races kilomètres à plus
de six minutes mais également pfr un
show floor à l'evo ali al et rosalie
lucas mis à les y gaiement
alors écoutez après donc ufr champions
puisque nous nous avons donc collé si la
bouée ces mutuelles marc gaillard 1 qui
va arriver suivi de gfa cotrel nord que
tout à l'heure et nous remontons donc en
compagnie du frh enfla est de brasserie
et de brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles
voilà donc je vous rappelle que vous
êtes a franchi la ligne d'arrivée a
donné une autre victoire d'étape à la
ville de france soir kelly babeau est l
opérationnel sur la ligne d'arrivée où
il ya une folle ambiance
mais surtout voir la lionne qui a
dessalé alors je vous explique ce qui
s'est passé ici au niveau de la ligne
d'arrivée les yoleurs était tellement
content d'arriver ici en première
position et d'entendre l'aller
l'ambiance ici sur la plage de leurs
supporteurs qu'ils ont laissé la yole du
salé petit coup même gros coup de colère
du patron aco qui n'était pas du tout
content de cette situation
et là il se retrouve en train d'essayer
de mettre la yole sur le sable ont de
façon à ce que les autres viols puisse
arriver en toute sécurité si alors on
essaie d'avoir à quoi qu'il arrive
pour cette première interview du
vainqueur de cette étape de cette 6e
étape
voilà donc à venir la réaction après sa
belle victoire
dako jacquat mali ont le battrons que
rosette orange alors pourquoi alors vous
l'aviez dit hier et même les gens
précédente
le tour n'est pas encore joué vous avez
réussi à faire ce tour de force
d'arriver en première possible
oui c'est vrai je dis on était très
motivés parce que on va en arriver à la
fin du tout et avoir eu deux victoires
parce qu'on va le public tout ça on a
envie de gagner
ben cette victoire je dédie cette
victoire en fait qui nous a laissés
jeune exilé à toute sa famille parce que
c'est estelle philippe l'équipage salut
l'entraîneur physique et cette victoire
c'est pour toute sa famille c'est pour
les jeunes et tous mes coups pied mais
sans oublier tous les franciscains
critique arrive en deuxième position
c'est c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
pour laurent soir cap la différence
qu'on vous juste avant note
ben c'est la voile ça avant un meeting
en toile les avants izard d'annoncé du
11 noeuds on a dit de façon laguiole qui
est quatrième il est à plus de 40
minutes on n'a rien à perdre
aujourd'hui on met le paquet mais tous
ont fait le tour pour la toux et ça nous
a réussi
merci pour j'aime bien savoir l'équipe à
chaussures ils ont tenu et c'est grâce à
eux ça pétille j'ai appelé la police
aura passé la ligne d'arrivée mais c'est
kelly pour la réaction d'autres dafoe
jacques attali qui a dédié sa belle
victoire d'étape à un gène exilique
décédée quatre minutes maintenant que
appétit n'a pas franchi la ligne
d'arrivée les calculs augmenté selon
rouge
oui les cavatines je pense qu'il y aura
deux minutes d'écart entre chacune en
moins sont plus seuls compteront se
trouvent ces tunnels est en train
d'arriver bon elle avait un précision on
me signale lui si il y à 4 minutes 20
secondes maintenant voir plus qu'un
rosette a franchi la ligne d'arrivée
alors dans le final maintenant nous
avons répété à l'image on reste avec
vous jean quel sera l'écart entre vous
êtes les appétits deuxième de cette
avant dernière étape du tour de
martinique
la v4 je pense dans les quatre cinq
minutes et à mon avis on est dans les
quatre cinq minutes parce que le voilà
elle va pas tarder à couper la ligne
d'arrivée
allait céder légèrement moins les
billets déjà brand il s'en moque un
petit peu mon ils voient qu'ils ont
moins cinq minutes d'avancé sur la yole
lui ai fait une chanson que nos
concurrents directs
la place de deuxième à la limite on est
un peu l'essentiel pour les artistes n'a
pas d'odeur jeudi c'était d'arriver
devant lier l'uefa champions 5 minutes
d'écart entre rosette/orange les
appétits gerber l'appaloosa les rosalies
de faire des calculs et des très fort en
mathématiques donc rosette qui a cinq
minutes d'avancé sur sap était alors une
autre duel pour la troisième et la
quatrième place à l'est aux amis
écoutent effectivement il y avait une
belle bagarre l'antre il a fait un
changement réel grâce il aurait le
sahara énergies nouvelles un temps
effectivement ufr arrivé et on ne
pensait même que la yole robertine
allait donc dépassé donc que la marée
noire
félix père est dans la tête de la pagaie
regarder toute l'énergie qu'il a mis
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs il a cédé sa
place
un peu et puis c'est peut-être fatigué
fait l'expérience qui s en prend
peut-être aussi à ces bois dressés
effectivement way petit là il va
demander donc aux produits bois dressés
donc d'être vie chez les regarde encore
un peu savoir le félix mérine mais c'est
vrai que on avait un moment donné toute
l'énergie qu'il a mis pour essayer
justement donc de coiffer bref il aurait
deux ports à cette troisième place mais
je pense que là voilà ce matin a dû
forcer donc félix mérine et caracoli
d'ailleurs kelly babeau posera sans
doute la question tout à l'heure aux
patrons donc de cet équipage
notez quand même que brasserie lorraine
terminera donc 3e et mieux sa chance la
quatrième heure